welcome back the new rock stars boys and
girls my name is Sam Bosch and I'm here
today to talk about Thor Ragnarok no I'm
not dissecting no the trailer but you
can't buy my comic-con trailer breakdown
on this channel I highly recommend it
today though I'm here to talk about the
future of the Thor franchise I may have
enjoyed the first Thor film a little bit
more than most people but the dark world
is pretty forgettable Ragnarok however
feels like a breath of fresh air no
longer are we dealing with these gods is
some kind of aliens with super advanced
technology that looks like magic no no
now it feels like these are the real
deal we're going up against the goddess
of death and based on that final shot of
the last trailer with Thor have
enlighten and shooting out of his pores
this looks like it's gonna be a real
Clash of the Titans it's very exciting I
know but where do we go from here sure
Thor has been confirmed for Avengers
infinity war and most likely the fourth
Avengers film but what about his
franchise Thor is one of Marvel's big
boys one of their top dogs and there's a
lot of lore that they could work through
in future films look the reason I'm here
today is because I believe we have hints
as to where these films could go hints
from the teasers and the trailers but
also from one of the producers of
Ragnarok and director Taika Waititi
himself here's the formal spoiler
warning for Thor Ragnarok the MCU and
some Marvel Comics let us begin recently
Ragnarok producer Brad winter hum was
asked which comic runs were used as
inspiration for the third outing of our
god of thunder
Brad stated we're pulling a lot
stylistically from Kirby but we're also
looking at Walt's Simonson's Ragnarok
arc and god of thunder the Jason Aaron
book we cherry picked really fun
elements out of it Simonson's Ragnarok
both stylistically and narrative Lee now
while the die-hard comic fans might be
losing their minds over this news let's
explain what this news means first up
pulling from Jack Kirby's time working
on Thor Jack Kirby for those of you who
aren't familiar with his work is the
ingenious mind behind some of the most
beautiful art in comics and of most of
the characters you love just for funsies
let's do a quick list you helped create
the whole the x-men the Fantastic Four
Silver Surfer Black Panther the New Gods
and the Avengers share their other
people who helped create these
characters and teams but Jack deserves
his credit Kirby also was very important
to Thor popping up in Marvel Comics
building on his look to what we all know
and love but also his world Kirby is
most well known for his literal
this world cosmic landscapes you know
super psychedelic mind-melting sequence
and dr. strangemoon benedict cumberbatch
which just flies through the multiverse
and then turns into a bunch of little
baby hands you think Jack Kirby for that
we even see a glimpse of some of Kirby's
stylings when we get a shot of the
buildings of Sekar and the grandmasters
statue these bright colors and whacky
designs are very reminiscent of Kirby's
creations for thor.fantastic four
and the New Gods you could even go as
far to say that the antenna on the top
of the Grand Master's Tower it looks
somewhat like Galactus is Lant lers
good-b maybe maybe not little nods like
this is what makes me so excited for
these movies so sang Jack Kirby is part
of the inspiration for this movie means
something good very exciting but what
about Walt Simonson so hold your horses
for a second while I pay respects to the
man who made Thor a freakin god - Norse
mythology of course horse mythology well
Simonson aka the other name attached to
Thor over at Marvel because Simonson at
some points single-handedly created some
of the most memorable parts of Thor's
lore that fans love and added many
aspects of Norse mythology to Thor
comics that really fleshed out the
characters
Simonson's four-year run with the Thor
title has been labeled by many his
legendary why you may ask well he
created a few iconic characters for
Marvel one being my personal favorite
throg Thor got turned into a frog for a
few issues is pretty epic don't worry he
turned back however throg returned to
comics eventually because apparently
there was a man who was turned into a
frog was hanging out with Thor who had
been turned into a frog and when the
Thor frog turned back into the Thor at
the God a little sliver of Mjolnir was
on the ground and the other frog picked
it up and have made a little mini-me
linear well I love comics now someone
else came up with the backstory for the
other throg was still this is just
amazing Simonson also created one other
character the most casual comic fans
should be familiar with who can also
wield the hammer of Thor and I'll come
back to that in a second also by the way
Simonson is the guy who came up with the
idea that meal near comes back to Thor
who doesn't love that idea
also worth mentioning Simonson created
one of the most unfortunately
forgettable villains in the MCU
Malekith the accused guy in dark world
great name kind of not great the movies
but I do love how he's using the most
recent Mighty Thor comic run Simonson
also did some great work with Fenrir the
wolf scourge the executioner and many
more that you're gonna see in thor
ragnarok the comics are
dated but I've heard that Simonson's run
is pretty good so I might check it out
here the final writer that winded him
mentions is a name that made my brain
start alight enough Jason Aaron Jason
Aaron's god of thunder books
specifically a book that most of my
friends and myself like to call one of
the best Odinson storylines period odin
sons referring to the thorak that is
played by Chris Hemsworth I know I've
mentioned a few Thor so to be specific
I'll use marvel's nickname for him from
now on
but back to the story Jason Aaron the
god of thunder storyline follows Odin
son through three different periods of
his life encountering a being known as
Gore the god butcher Gore's drive-in
life is pretty interesting mainly it's
to kill all gods in the Marvel Universe
because who needs him really that's it
he's like literally a serial killer but
he does have some good points but it's
worth mentioning one of Gore's main
powers is the ability to manifest
weapons
sound familiar and it sounds like the
moved hell up holes out in the middle of
the thor ragnarok trailer I'm a confused
mmm not mistaken also director Taika
Waititi back this up in an interview the
villain gore has a very specific power
of being able to manifest an infinite
number of weapons we've drafted that
idea and are doing a version of that for
hella in our movie that's very cool the
entire story of Ragnarok is very
interesting the idea of death and
rebirth plus you're dealing with the
goddess of death which is kind of
basically the same as like God butcher
in the general sense right just don't
fight me on this it's not the point of
this video she kills gods he kills gods
my point is them mentioning Gore could
be a signal for where we could see Odin
Sun in the future let me explain in the
god of thunder storyline Gore's main
directive is to eliminate all living
deities because he believes they're not
needed nor are they worth the adoration
they received from mortals okay
they don't do while Odinson opposes
gore the god butchers ideas stick with
Odin's son and eventually having to get
into too may spoilers for a number of
comic book storylines the idea that
Noah's guardians are worthy of their
divinity and adoration rocks Odin son so
much that he becomes unworthy of his
hammer Thor can no longer hold his
hammer he leaves it on the moon now
doesn't that whole story sound somewhat
familiar possibly because that's what
sounds like you know Thor Ragnarok is
exploring a little bit sure we're not
dealing with gore or the death of all
gods in the universe but we are dealing
with the death of some deities the ones
we
lino in the MCU specifically the
Asgardians in short in the story of
Ragnarok the gods and Asgard all die and
are reborn and hella wants to bring this
to fruition and while we don't know his
exact motivation for this movie my guess
is that she's pretty angry at the
Asgardians probably for being locked up
in hell or wherever she was for however
many centuries maybe she's not feeling
that the Asgardians are worthy of their
praise any longer now just throw in
Gore's ability to manifest weapons and
some things start to click into place
sure mister taiga when T V stated they
picked specific pieces they liked from
Jason Aaron's story it ends straight
adapt the whole thing but they're with
me
Odin son is without his hammer for a
majority of this movie we can assume yes
at the very least we see me on there it
gets smushed in Hellas hands
do you think it's possible that the
reason Odinson wasn't able to take the
hammer back from her was because she
instilled some doubt in the god of
thunder maybe Odin's son doesn't feel
that he's worthy of the power of Thor
any longer this could be how hella is
able to get the upper hand and destroy
the hammer but of course she could just
be that Oh Pete to be fair what I'm
getting at is that maybe by the end of
Thor Ragnarok Odinson no longer feels
that he is worthy enough to be Thor now
I know what you're gonna say
millionnaire was seen on the set of
Avengers infinity war and from what I've
researched Chris Hemsworth will be in
Avengers 4 but hear me out for just a
second here's what I'm thinking by the
end of this third Thor movie houghton
son gets the hammer back because he
realizes that he's worthy or he makes a
new hammer or the hammer puts itself
back together it doesn't really matter
but he starts the question if the gods
are truly worthy of wielding this great
power password through two Avengers
movies and I see a few scenarios Odinson
stays his Thor in the status quo stays
the same and for the god of thunder
that's whatever kind of boring in my
opinion - Odin son dies because the
Russo brothers said that we'd lose some
big-name teammates or three he decides
he actually isn't worthy and he leaves
the hammer for someone else to pick up
the mantle while he travels the Kosmos
or rebuilds Asgard or dies a farm next
to his buddy Clint and they all just
don't live together they all family
personally I prefer the last two options
I think this could be a really unique
way to give Chris Hemsworth some
much-needed rest from playing Thor for a
few years you know maybe and allow one
of the many legacy characters to take up
the mantle of Thor it sounds to me like
the most logical way not to burn out
your actors and keep them interested in
coming back for cameos
that's what we want now you're all
probably starting to get curious which
legacy characters am i referring to well
first off for those of you who don't
know legacy character means someone who
took up the mantle of a classic
character example Wally West takes over
Barry Allen's place as the flash or more
recently Miles Morales takes over as
spider-man or just became a second
environment it's confusing for Thor
however we have a few options and the
first one on my mind is an original
creation from the one and only Walt
Simonson now I mentioned this guy
earlier anyone familiar with a certain
korbinite warrior who is worthy of
wielding meal in their own home not even
sure what a korbinite is it's an alien
race kind of like horses that walk on
two feet and marvel comic's that we've
actually seen hints of in the movies but
poem two that thought for just a second
I'm talking about mr. beta ray bill this
fan favorite character popped up during
Simonson's dynasty has been an important
part of Thor's comic lore ever since
now who is beta ray bill well this
character appeared in November 1983
during the whole Odin Sun turned into a
frog arc and was the first being outside
of Asgard to wield Mjolnir Odin was
impressed by Bill and then fashioned him
his very own hammer named star breaker
oh that is cool looking as Thor's hammer
in my opinion but who cares what I think
beta ray bill is awesome now I know what
you thinking this horse looking dude
hasn't appeared in the movies yet how
would an audience get behind such a
character well first off we actually got
a tease of the korbinite race existing
in guardians the galaxy vol 1 remember
the opening scene where star Loras
dancin on that dead planet looking for
that orb with the purple thing in it and
you see that skeleton and he gives it a
spin BAM
that's a korbinite skeleton I don't know
who's never confirmed but I mean come on
Marvel doesn't tease us for nothing
right as for how bill could be
introduced in Ragnarok and future movies
tricky I'll give you that in thor
ragnarok trailer breakdown we made I
stated that I believe the horse face
being on the side of the Grand Master's
tower was most likely beta ray bill or
at least someone from the korbinite race
now there's a chance a slim one based on
how big this cast is for the movie but
still a chance that beta ray bill could
make a cameo in Thor Ragnarok during the
gladiator matches on Sekar he does play
a role in the Planet Hulk storyline
which is basically the first half of
what this movie seems to be based on so
my guess is that he's a hidden member of
Team Thor or the revenger
as Odinson called it in that one TV spot
so bill could make an appearance as one
of the fighters on the planet ups a car
fighting for the Grand Master I'm even
thinking that bill could be one of the
fighters that leaves an uprising on
Sekar and helps Team Thor escape this
could open the door to bill playing a
big part in Avengers infinity war and
beyond as a sidekick to Odin's son with
his own hammer and could lead to him
starring his own movie but that sounds
like a bit of a stretch right I have to
agree but not about him making an
appearance I'm standing by that but I
think I have an idea for another
character that could take up the mantle
of Thor now get ready because this next
fan theory that came to me made me so
freaking excited are you prepared if
you're not familiar at the end of the
era in comics of Odin's son with the
power of Thor after gorse words finally
take hold in his mind and make him
unworthy to wield the hammer a new
individual is revealed to be worthy
enough to hold Mueller and Marvel gave
unto us a gift we received the all-new
Mighty Thor a mysterious woman whose
identity was hidden from us until the
last year or so the character was
revealed to be someone who played a
major role in the life of Odin's son and
has played a fairly major role in a
majority of the Thor films thus far now
I'm pretty sure you're all aware that
the original team Thor in Thor 1 and the
dark world cat Denning is mr. skarsgård
and Miss Natalie Portman would not be
returning for Ragnarok however I'm not
buying it Marvel duped us in x-men Days
of Future past when beasts Cyclops and
Jean Grey return came falling for again
I'm a feeling that while in New York
Loki and Odin's son who be hunting down
dr. strange and a hidden Odin in Central
Park pretend to be a homeless man and
quite possibly we could see the return
of Natalie Portman I know a lot of fans
weren't the biggest fans of her betrayal
of dr. Jane Foster but hear me out for
just a second comic book Jane Foster was
revealed to be the secret identity of
the all-new Thor while fans of a classic
Thor were obviously upset because that's
what fans do she has had a pretty
amazing comic run let's be honest and
her character in my opinion has a far
more interesting journey than an
omnipotent God my theory Marvel is going
to be looking for new characters to be
going out on their own adventures in
phase 4 and Beyond and Thor's always
played an important role on the Avengers
but it didn't always matter which
version of Thor was on the team I
I think it'd be very cool to see more
female at Marvel movies and Jane Foster
Thor would be a perfect candidate why
because her whole story revolves around
her battle with cancer while she does go
through chemo every time Jane picks up
the hammer she transforms into Thor
purging the cancer and the chemicals
from the chemotherapy from her body
however every time she transforms back
into a human the cancer returns as well
right back to the state it was before
the chemo could take effect so right off
the bat you have a compelling character
who has the opportunity to turn into a
god become a superhero but it's killing
her also the idea of humans overcoming
their own shortcomings and becoming
worthy enough for me linear sounds like
a pretty epic storyline now Marvel went
with a story they could still have Chris
Hemsworth pop up in the background is
someone who knows supports Jane during
her time of need
there's also hunting down this new Thor
because he's worried alright so I mean
Leia SHhhh the story
you'rewelcome Marvel you're he told this
story in the comics but I'm just getting
excited about it and to maybe quell some
of your concerns about Natalie Portman's
betrayal of Jane Foster so far remember
this a lot of people weren't the biggest
fans of the first Captain America movie
then came the Russo brothers and made a
Winter Soldier and in civil war and holy
crap Kat became such a freakin legend
sometimes you just need the right
creative team I think seeing a human
being given the powers of a literal God
and taking on God level threats while
battling cancer could be a freakin
badass revolutionary superhero but hey
that's just me they even throw beta ray
bill in that film he does appear in
Ragnarok or in future films as you know
like her partner I possibly have
Valkyrie Tessa Thompson and Jane team-up
for one of the first female led team-up
superhero movies vocal oops I just sold
myself on that idea now again these are
just my theories these could all be
wrong come November at the very least
we're all about to be treated to some
curvy and simonson inspired art and
production design on the big screen
that's just gonna be wonderful but what
do you guys think do you think I'm on to
something or am I just a wee bit crazy I
see potential in this new Thor franchise
that mr. white TT is creating and the
risks he and Marvel are taking so why
not go a step further start discussing
this ASAP in the comments down below
also tweet me your thoughts and opinions
am I totally wrong in this next door
movie is actually just gonna be about
throg I'd love it damn I set myself on
another one of my ideas if you guys like
to get in touch I'm Sam basher on
Twitter I'd love to hear what you guys
have to say give this video a like and
sub to New Rock sirs if you haven't
already also go check out all the other
awesome
breakdowns that we have on this channel
they're very cool have fun
your crazy kids I'll see you next time